We said like well there should be some
priors in humans about how we can uh
find authenticity how we can ensure that
it's really a human right like it's a
real video. Um so in that sense we
actually looked at like what can be that
like um generalizable um prior in humans
and we said well maybe the blood you
know like all of us have blood all of us
have like a heart um maybe we can look
at the heart of the deep fakes and real
videos. So that's how actually the fake
catcher started.
[Music]
Il Demier, welcome to the human zero
day. I'm so honored to have uh you know
this time with you h to talk about some
of the most amazing work that you've
been doing which has been really
inspiring for me following from the
sidelines and not just because of how
cool it is but also I see the impact
that it's creating and the way that
you're talking about it is is the really
really awesome. So thank you so much for
agreeing to be here.
>> Of course. Thanks for the invitation and
I'm super uh hyped to talk about
everything that we do.
>> I love it. So, Ilka, you're dealing
today with one of the most pressing
issues erh that societyy's facing. The
issue of deep fakes, the issue of trust
in media within Intel, you're in trusted
media team. You're also the inventor of
the fake catcher. H the name speaks for
itself. What is what what does it mean a
a fake catcher? That's a not a trivial
name to choose for any any solution.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, so fake catcher is
actually like um more than five years
old at this point that um it was just a
curiosity about like what we can do
about deep fakes. You know, at that time
we were seeing those like new GAN
approaches like one or two like um good
deep fakes that are coming off. Everyone
was saying oh that's a niche area. Yeah.
Yeah. Humans have been replicated for so
long. uh but we said like well there
should be some priors in humans about
how we can uh find authenticity how we
can ensure that it's really a human
right like it's a real video. Um so in
that sense we actually looked at like
what can be that like um generalizable
um prior in humans and we said well
maybe the blood you know like all of us
have blood all of us have like a heart
um maybe we can look at the heart of the
deep fakes and real videos. So that's
how actually fake catcher started. Fake
catcher is a deep fake detection
algorithm that is looking at biological
signals um specifically the heart rate
and blood flow on your skin.
We're gonna So, we're going to dive into
all that. That's fascinating. And I
think when you actually look at what
deep fakes are, you know, these nonhuman
impersonation of humans, it seems only
fitting that you will use human
biological signals to discern what is
human and what is not. Before we get
there, you actually still started your
journey in computational geometry,
right?
>> Yes. Yes, that's true.
>> How tell me about that journey.
>> Yeah. Yeah, of course. Um, so my uh PhD
and uh all my life was on traditional
generative models which are like
procedural models, inverse procedural
modeling. Um, all that graphics was how
we can actually create 3D data, how we
can analyze 3D data, find the rules and
al systems and grammarss from 3D data.
So my PhD was on all of that. Um and
then like we branch from everything from
we branch even to like 3D printing to um
3D construction to like many things. Um
well defect detection already only
started as a um uh curiosity like at
that time I was working on um human
understanding in virtual reality. So how
we can actually um look at our eyes and
maybe predict the next gaze or how we
can actually look at the hands, how we
can look at the expressions and try to
understand something about about humans
in VR space. Um and that was already
giving some um clues about like humans
being predictable, humans having those
signals, right? And when defects were
emerging um I switched a little bit just
with with this project with the
curiosity but then um throughout the
life of um um I think my team in Intel
my position uh we said let's actually
like uh explore more so uh after fake
catcher we did many different detectors
then we started doing like is possible
generative models looking at media
provenence etc. So I think the whole
transition started as a as a curiosity
for me. Um I I never left the 3D world
either. So we still have many projects
on like gash and splats or nerves or
like any other like the 3D approaches
that you may think of but it's not the
main focus right now.
>> Wow. Okay. So it's you know take me five
years ago to to really the the creation
of the fake catcher. So you know where
are you? What's happening? What is
making you say this is what I'm going to
do now and did you know that 5 years
down the line you're still going to be
doing it but obviously you know leading
it bigger and bigger.
>> Yeah, great question. I think I will
start from the end. I think I wouldn't
have thought about like still working on
a catcher up to date. I would have uh
imagined like I would be working on like
different um different research area not
different research areas but different
research topics not catcher. So um so as
I said like we were looking at like um
human understanding in virtual reality
and then um I said like there should be
some priors in humans um and at that
point I think in I don't remember where
but like in one of the topics or like
research teams or um at some point I saw
the 2012 paper from um uh Bill Freeman's
uh group at MIT which is one of the
first photography papers PP PG uh papers
for those that don't know that big word
photoismography
that is um finding the heart rate from
videos. So you know like we go to like
physical devices and they find our heart
heartbeats, heart rates um you can
actually do it remotely and that has
been used in like patient monitoring uh
for for some time. So um that's um
looking at the color composition from
the skin and uh understanding your heart
rate. So that's like um
photoflatismography. Anyway, then one of
the first like remote
photoflatismography papers from uh MIT.
I saw it and I'm like well this is
actually this sounds like a
generalizable um biological signal that
we all have. Um and then I called my uh
colleague uh who is the expert on PPG
called like Omar Chief um he's a
professor in Bingington University and
he's like come actually like extract
those signals do some experiments like
just just out of curiosity just like
extract me the signals and we will do
the rest. Um and at that point it was
not even like uh yeah we we had like
narrow networks as CNN's and LSTMs and
other things but we um to actually
understand the feature space we just
threw S SVMs on them right like support
vector machines on them and um try to
find like what the feature space looks
like um how we can actually um find some
distection of real and fake signals in
that space etc. And then it evolved to
fake catcher basically.
>> Wow. Okay. And when you started fake
catcher in the beginning, so it's it
sounds like you started it with an
insight as to here's something that we
can do which would be one different, two
unique, three maybe work, right? I mean
it sounds and really cool. That's a
fourth one. How you know was it smooth
sailing from the start? the the the
introduction of fake catcher.
>> How
I mean we did many experiments. Um and
it is like when you start a new project
like that and me myself I never worked
in PPG before but I was so lucky to have
my collaborator that actually um like a
part of his PhD thesis actually about
like PPG signals and how we can actually
process faces to have reliable PPG
signals etc. Um so um we I think there
was some at the beginning there was some
like um persevering period but like we
really think there is something in there
but how you represent that signal was
important right because that signal is
not like super robust like you don't
like exactly see okay this is a senoidal
beautiful heart rate pattern in a heart
rate monitor you know um instead like we
looked at their differences we looked at
the different ppg
types like GPPG, Chrome, PPPG etc. Uh we
looked at different data sets to
understand like how we are actually um
uh robust against like different
illuminations, different like occlusions
etc. Um so all of these we try to
combine together um and at some point we
we get a grasp of like what's happening
with the signals and after that we
actually designed the experiments to um
highlight how they are powerful how they
are not powerful and then after the SVM
space we went to like we we we decided
to use a simple CNN so that it is more
robust to all those like artifacts that
we uh mentioned that may be affecting
the signals. Um then after having the
CNN we really um saw that like yes this
is actually working like this is
actually giving us results etc. So yeah
there was in the rough start uh to
understand how they behave but after
that um the experiments were going well
>> and so one of the things that we've been
hearing in the space is that there's
often you know there's the lab and then
there's the world
>> and the world behaves differently than
the lab. um
various diversity
different you know everything changes.
How true is that for deep face as well?
>> Oh absolutely so true. Um so the very
first um data sets that we all started
using is like beautiful data sets like
I'm glad like all the data set creators
are creating those data sets but that's
not actually um uh as as time passes
more and more generators come more and
more image process and video processing
tools emerge. Um and uh those in the
wild cases are um diverging from the
clean lab data sets that we have. Um our
very first attempt to um um show
generalizability and show that in the
wild we can also process well is that is
to create those defects in the wild data
set. That's also um that was also
released with fake catcher. Um and that
was like the first attempt to actually
gather all those like niche videos that
are in the wild you know the first data
sets uh that the first videos that
appeared in YouTube Twitter research
presentations like we gathered all the
defects in the wild that we can see and
uh we evalated fake catcher on that and
we had 91.07% 07% accuracy. And that was
actually hopeful because at that time
like none of those in the wild cases
were actually covered well because
that's understandable because at that
time like the there was almost no
biological defect detectors. All of them
were um all of those like blind
detectors were conforming to the data
sets that they are trained on. Like it
has 99% on face forensics. Let's let's
say a detector has 99% on face forensics
and then uh you uh try it on defects in
the V and like 50%. Great you know of
course because like it is actually
learning the data set it's not learning
what is real or fake. So that was our
first attempt and up to date it's still
like that like you know like um the um
in the wild videos that we see are
different from the um uh uh clean lab
data sets and that's why like the more
we um see more data sets we try to
understand like what is going wrong is
there a new artifact is there a new
generator is there a new editing tool is
it like a localized deep fake uh the
localized manipulation to create that
deep fake is it a multimodel deep fake
but I see true what I hear is not true
etc. So all those branching from there
um and it's very important to if you
really want to do you're also doing the
same thing so like um like not same
thing but like similar thing that like
we are all trying to put a um product
into the world that can like battle all
those cases. Um and for productization
it's really important to understand the
failures and the limitations so that you
can actually feed in more data either
synthetic data or real world data to
battle those uh in the wild case.
>> Absolutely. And you know I think that
one of the things that
you know we we discovered in our in our
research in our work is that this
problem of out of distribution and
generalizability is a really really
difficult one when it comes to deep
fakes and and you know we just talked
about this but I think that you know
it's very similar I think to to malware
and and how malware came about in 2000
with different permutations and
different branches and and sure back
then you were able to have these
pretty robust firewall signatures to be
able to identify the malware. But I
think with with deep fakes, we're
pressed against additional challenges
like video resolution, audio resolution,
um not to mention different skin colors
and accents and you know, we're both
we're we're in the sitting with a few,
you know, human rights organizations and
and we see we see media coming in and
you're like, "Wow, this is like really
hard stuff." You know, the real world is
hard. H now it could be that all that
you know we we don't look at blood flow
so it could be that this biological
method generalizes better because you're
you're looking at at humans. Um but yeah
at least we discovered that it would
make more sense for us to be more narrow
in our thinking and in our research
>> so that we can be really really good at
something. uh and uh it's a startup
advice we also got from an Eric Schmidt
a while back uh when we just started
doing our deep fake work. Now, okay, I'm
I'm curious, you know, you've been being
at the forefront of deep fake detection.
You've also been at the forefront in in
the media about this, right? You've been
appearing and you've been talking about
it. You've you've presented papers in
some of the biggest conferences. So,
you've been out there
You're seeing the market. You're seeing
how the world is responding. Who needs
it? Who doesn't need it? Who thought
they may need it but doesn't really use
it. What are you seeing? How is the
world responding to deep fakes today in
December of 2024?
>> Yeah. So I think recently like um it was
like up until the elections it was like
so much um
I don't want to say fear but so much
expectation about um there will be
something with elections that we need to
be ready and deep fakes are coming. Uh
but it was not like suddenly an
exponential curve of defects. It was
like the regular defects that we are
that we see around um some of the like
you know like with the new like
diffusion models and stuff like some of
the new image editing and image
manipulation techniques etc. But there
was not that catastrophic event that
affects deep um elections with deep
fakes. Um and I think we are seeing more
and more and what is happening is um
instead of um
trying to differentiate deep fakes, we
are going to an era that even if it is
AI generated or AI manipulated, can we
understand the actual messaging to be
misleading or not? you know um taking it
a little bit more from the visual and
audio analysis to a little bit to the
context and meaning analysis.
>> Wow. Um so I think that is the most
because like the AI tools and AI um
effects or filters or you know um
everything that we do with um like
it's not like real or deep fake. There's
a whole range between them and it is
becoming that whole range in between
then that like all the way to having
just one touch from Photoshop to um deep
fake but it's my own deep fake because I
didn't have time to attend this uh call
for example right um so
instead of like having that mechanical
analysis uh going more to the um
contextual analysis and even like
societal analysis about how a video is
impacting is it is it's if its messaging
is actually helping or hurting um real
or like correct or not incorrect or
manipulative
um so I think that's where we are going
um of course I'm not saying that the
effect detection tools are becoming
obsolid they are for sure and we need to
know like all the history of the that's
why we work on provenence right we need
to work know the whole history of the
media about like who edited who created
who was the voice actor who did the
distribution etc. So that we know
everything about the media but you can
know everything about the media um and
it is all useless if you don't know the
intent of the media and that's the
hardest part.
>> Absolutely. So, where do you based on
your understanding of deep fake
detection in the market? Because people
have been looking at, you know, this
problem of the authenticity of a piece
of digital media from def from a
detection perspective, providence,
authentication, maybe even watermarking
and prevention,
>> right?
>> Where where do you see defay detection
being most suitable long term? So, if
we're thinking about this detection me,
this technology of being able to run
advanced AI to try and discern whether
this media was manipulated or tampered
with AI, where would this given what we
know about the technology and the
progress, where do you think it will be
most successful in creating real value?
Mhm. So when we
built trusted media, our moto or our
belief was always um
defect detection is a temporary solution
in an ideal world in n years uh we will
have provenence data with all the media
so that we won't need detection and the
more you actually you are also in the
same ecosystem so you also know that
like the more uh we are in this
ecosystem the more we see the provenence
approaches their implementations etc
that um the more we see that this
utopian everything will have provenence
idea is getting longer and longer and
longer and longer with very various
reasons right like all editing tools or
or capture tools or all generation tools
like everyone needs to be on the same
page to actually have provenence and
like um I I may be um talking a little
bit too much like C2PA a uh mindset um
doesn't need to be CTP it like it's
great that if that is as a standard but
like as long as uh a hypothetical
provenence solution is attached to all
data then at that point hopefully you
won't need detection but it is getting a
longer longer longer longer feature um
that we will always need detection in
the sense that um learning something
about the data you know like something
about in the vital data um what we can
um like can we know whether it's real or
fake of course but there's also
something that we work on called um
backwards provenence and that is about
whatever we can decipher about origins
of data right so we do source detection
for example can we find out which
generative model created this if it is a
fake video if it's a deep fake video can
we find the source material that created
that even if like can we find the
speaker in that video so that we can
compare there with the authentic um
samples of that speaker versus the um
this version that we don't know what is
real or fake etc. So finding anything
about the um uh video to uh find that
puzzle pieces that creates the
provenence information is very important
and detection is definitely a part of
it.
>> Absolutely. So, what are you most
excited about coming up?
>> Um, so there are many news that I want
to give but I cannot give those news
right now. So, just like a a few more
months for those news.
uh in general what I'm uh I'm uh very
excited about is um now everyone is
trying to approach this pro problem not
as a technical problem but as a social
technical problem right not only looking
for whether something goes real is real
or because we have many detectors right
like we have I mean at least even just
within my team we have fake catcher we
have eye gazebased detection we have
motion based detection we have
multimodel det detection. We have audio
only detection that is like working
super nicely right now. I'm I'm I'm
proud of that work. Um but like beyond
that, we are also trying to understand
where humans um stand in this in this
system, right? Like how humans interact
like we have several user studies about
understanding how humans perceive fake
content. Um, is there verticals in the
user or is there verticals in the
content that we can match or we can uh
that are tangential that affects the um
uh perception of like if if it's in the
same demographics as me, do I have a
more critical eye about understanding
what it's real or fake or is there like
a generalized version that um I don't
know like I don't want to give some of
the results but like some maybe um young
male
um uh white demographics are perceived
to be more fake than more real just
because those are the examples that
people see around the world etc. Anyway,
so um and also like the humans
perception with the defect detection
results, right? Like if we just say
likely real, likely fake, is it more
helpful? Or if we say 95% fake according
to the PPG signals that are found on
display on the face, is it overwhelming?
Is it helping better etc. So all those
like interpretability, explanability
um and uncertainty factors that that
bleed into all these like technical
systems that we uh develop. How do we
explain that to the public? How do we
explain it to the humans? What people
get from there like how to make it more
trustworthy so that humans use it etc.
So those um and not not just for for uh
like uh trusted media or like for for my
work, right? like as a whole ecosystem
we are realizing that it's not only the
technical detectors or like uh battling
AI with AI but humans are actually still
at the heart of it. So how we
communicate with humans, how we utilize
humans, how we um enable humans or armor
humans is um something I'm super excited
about.
>> Okay. so many things to be proud of and
thank you for taking this time to uh to
inspire me and and and everybody else
that that will be seeing this. I really
want to thank you for for your time and
for your work. Um I'm excited to keep on
following and uh and being impressed and
and thank you very much for being here.
>> Absolutely. Thank you. This was like a
very very exciting conversation. Thank
you. Thank you.